WE'RE GETTING AN ANNOUNCEMENT
FROM ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK
GARLAND SET TO APPOINT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL IN THE TRUMP PROBE.
>> Reporter: THAT'S RIGHT.
SO IN THE NEXT 20 MINUTES OR SO
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL DIRECTLY, BUT
HE IS -- HE HAS APPOINTED A
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO OVERSEE THE
INVESTIGATION -- THE TWIN
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, ONE OF THEM OF COURSE
IS THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S
INVESTIGATION OF THE RETENTION
OF NATIONAL SECURITY INFORMATION
THESE ARE THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE FOUND BY THE
FBI DURING THE SEARCH AT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S RESIDENCE IN
PALM BEACH IN MAR-A-LAGO, THE
SECOND PART OF THIS IS PARTS OF
THE JANUARY 6th INVESTIGATION
THAT TOUCH ON THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
OF COURSE, YOU KNOW THAT ONE OF
THE THINGS THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN LOOKING INTO
IS THE INVOLVEMENT OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND THE PEOPLE AROUND
HIM IN THE EFFORT TO OBSTRUCT
THE TRANSFER OF POWER AFTER
THE -- AFTER THE 2020 ELECTION.
HE WAS INVOLVED IN THE FAKE
ELECTORS SCHEME AND IN THE
ENTIRE EFFORT TO TRY TO PREVENT
CONGRESS FROM CERTIFYING JOE
BIDEN'S VICTORY AT THE END OF
THE 2020 ELECTION.
THOSE ARE THE TWO THINGS THAT
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL WHO HAS
ALREADY BEEN APPOINTED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO IS NOW
GOING TO OVERSEE THOSE TWO SEE
ASPECTS OF THESE TWO
INVESTIGATIONS.
NOW, WE'RE GOING TO HEAR A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WHO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS APPOINTED
WHEN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL COMES
OUT TO SPEAK, AGAIN, IN ABOUT 30
MINUTES OR SO AND WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR A LOT MORE ABOUT EXACTLY
WHY THIS WAS DONE, BUT, LOOK, WE
PREVIOUSLY REPORTED WE BROKE THE
STORY HERE AT CNN THAT THIS WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS IN DISCUSSION
AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
PART OF THE CALCULATION WAS THE
IDEA THAT, YOU KNOW, HAVING
SOMEONE NOT PART OF THE
POLITICAL LEADERSHIP HERE UNDER
THE POLITICAL LEADERSHIP HERE
OVERSEEING THESE INVESTIGATIONS
WAS IMPORTANT IF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT DECLARES THAT HE IS A
CANDIDATE FOR OFFICE ONCE MORE,
GIVEN THE FACT THAT OBVIOUSLY HE
MIGHT BE RUNNING AGAINST MERRICK
GARLAND, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
BOSS, JOE BIDEN, IF HE DECIDES
TO RUN FOR REELECTION SO THAT'S
PART OF THE ISSUE, WHICH WAS TO
TRY TO INSULATE THOSE TWO
INVESTIGATIONS AND KEEP THEM OUT
OF THE REALM OF POLITICS.
OF COURSE, YOU GUYS KNOW THAT,
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN TRY TO DO
THAT, BUT THEN OF COURSE IT HAS
TO DO WITH DONALD TRUMP AND
THERE'S PROBABLY NO WAY TO
DIVORCE YOURSELF ENTIRELY FROM
THE POLITICAL ATMOSPHERE OF
THIS.
>> EVAN, STAY WITH ME I WANT TO
BRING IN JESSICA SCHNEIDER WHO
IS LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE S
DELIBERATIONS THAT TOOK PLACE TO
GET TO THIS POINT.
>> AS EVAN JUST MENTIONED HERE
IT WAS OUR TEAM TWO WEEKS AGO
THAT BROKE THAT NEWS THAT THE
DOJ WAS CONSIDERING WHETHER OR
NOT A SPECIAL COUNSEL WOULD BE
NECESSARY ONCE TRUMP ANNOUNCED
HIS CANDIDACY FOR A SECOND TERM.
OF COURSE, THAT ANNOUNCEMENT
HAPPENING EARLIER THIS WEEK ON
TUESDAY NIGHT.
SO PRESUMABLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
ACTING FAIRLY QUICKLY HERE
WITHIN A MATTER OF DAYS TO
DECIDE TO NAME A SPECIAL COUNSEL
TO OVERSEE THESE TWO PARALLEL
AND VERY BIG PROBES THAT ARE
ONGOING, INTO JANUARY 6th AND
ALSO THE ALLEGED RETENTION OF
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S HOME IN PALM
BEACH, FLORIDA, MAR-A-LAGO.
SO THIS HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT
THE DOJ HAS BEEN CONSIDERING FOR
MANY WEEKS, AS ALL OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS HAVE REALLY
CRESCENDOED AND THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT WILL BE COMING
TODAY FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
MERRICK GARLAND.
EVAN TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT A
SPECIAL COUNSEL, THE FACT THAT
IT CAN SOMEWHAT INSULATE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FROM ANY
CRIES OF POLITICIZATION HERE.
OF COURSE, THOSE CRIES ARE GOING
TO COME INEVITABLY.
BUT ULTIMATELY WHAT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE HERE IS THAT EVEN THOUGH
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL WILL BE
NAMED VERY SHORTLY BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, HE WILL REVEAL
WHO IT IS, THAT SPECIAL COUNSEL
WILL OPERATE INDEPENDENTLY,
HOWEVER, ULTIMATELY ANY
DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER TO
CHARGE THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
DONALD TRUMP, OR ANY OF HIS
ASSOCIATES, THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WILL, IN FACT, BE RUN BY
AND APPROVED ULTIMATELY BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND TOP
OFFICIALS AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
OF COURSE, THE UNITED STATES
PUBLIC HAS SEEN THIS BEFORE, WE
SAW ROBERT MUELLER BE NAMED AS
SPECIAL COUNSEL BY THEN DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN,
THAT WAS WAY BACK IN 2017.
WE SAW THAT PROBE ONGOING FOR AT
LEAST A YEAR AND A HALF, I
BELIEVE.
AND THEN OF COURSE WE STILL HAVE
A SPECIAL COUNSEL, JOHN DURHAM,
WHO HAS BEEN ONGOING AND
ACTUALLY UNSUCCESSFUL IN SEVERAL
PROSECUTIONS THAT HE HAS
BROUGHT.
SO THIS WILL BE A SPECIAL
COUNSEL THAT WILL BE ANNOUNCED
BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, WE ARE
EXPECTING THAT LIVE ANNOUNCEMENT
AT 2:15, PRESUMABLY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WILL NAME WHO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL WILL BE AND THEN
EXPLAIN THE PARAMETERS OF THIS
INVESTIGATION AND WHAT HE WILL
BE OVERSEEING.
BUT, ANA, IT WILL BE QUITE BROAD
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THESE TWO
PARALLEL TRACKS INTO THE
PRESIDENT'S -- FORMER
PRESIDENT'S INVOLVEMENT IN
JANUARY 6, TRYING TO OVERTURN
THE 2020 ELECTION AND THEN OF
COURSE THAT CONTINUING
INVESTIGATION THAT POPPED UP
OVER THE SUMMER THAT WE ALL
LEARNED ABOUT INTO THE ALLEGED
RETENTION OF CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AT MAR-A-LAGO.
SO EXPECTING MORE FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN JUST ABOUT A
HALF HOUR HERE, ANA.
>> DO WE KNOW WHO HE IS PLANNING
TO APPOINT OR IS HE JUST GOING
TO ANNOUNCE HE HAS MADE A
DECISION TO HAVE A SPECIAL
COUNSEL?
>> YEAH, I KNOW EVAN IS ACTUALLY
OVER AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
HE SEEMED TO INDICATE THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL PROBABLY
NAME WHO THE SPECIAL COUNSEL IS
AND BRINGING YOU BACK TO 2017
WHEN ROD ROSENSTEIN ANNOUNCED
THAT THERE WOULD BE A SPECIAL
COUNSEL, HE DID NAME THAT IT
WOULD BE ROBERT MUELLER RIGHT
AWAY.
SO IT'S EXPECTED THAT ATTORNEY
GENERAL GARLAND WILL DO THE SAME
HERE AND ANNOUNCE WHO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL ACTUALLY WILL
BE, BUT WE WILL STAY TUNED FOR
THAT.